[موسيقى]
ا
something
[موسيقى]
like
still his mother to wored sheed
her years later he goes to school with
he can't
even
[موسيقى]
المدرسه
الم
ربنا سهل الموع وان خلقنا كلنا زي بعض
بالبط
لحجه في يوم من الايام
[موسيقى]
حلال
حعش الفك
مشص
القت education systems i start to the
national system in a fr school followed
by the american system followed by the
british system and next year most
joining the ib system surprisingly i
don't fit into any of them i simply
didn't see myself in any of the systems
and like everything everything has the
two sides of the coin so is the systems
starting with the british system the
british system only depends on
memorizing and exams and studying but on
the other hand it actually gets out a
professional students in most of the
aspects moving to the american system it
gets out a really outspoken
student with a really strong personality
who can talk in front of millions but it
has really weak content compared to the
rest of the systems moving finally to
the national system it's the easiest to
enter cheapest accepted the most of
universities but depends on all
memorizing all we need is simply a
system that combines all the positive
aspects of these system
sy that
students actually every sle type
ofar in this it shows some figures who
actually drop out of school but look at
them these figures make they actually
left fingerprint on daily lives they
made history the unqualified squ
actually make da life
easier some of these examples are b
gates
كير
لا st of the unqualified einstein there
are millions of einstein sitting in
front of so please don't conce them
but